good morning good afternoon
depending on where you are in the world
um my name is sue keeler
and i've worked in the clinical trials
bioanalysis
world for in excess of 30 years now
and i was so frustrated when i worked in
a
large pharma that sample operations in a
clinical trial
was never given a very high priority
so because that frustrated me i decided
to
go out and set up a company that purely
focused
on that and i do believe that calibri is
making a real difference in this space
but i can absolutely guarantee you that
i'm not going to try and sell anything
this is a
completely non-commercial talk um
i just wanted to share our experiences
of how we use our limb system to
automate
um the the management process and
um we have a particular um
focus on gcp
so um just a very quick overview
a very high level summary i'll start
with what the
regulatory authority expectations are
look at the pitfalls i really don't like
to talk about negative things
during a presentation so i'll keep that
to one flight i absolutely promise you
and then we'll look at how we can avoid
those pitfalls
um through the use of our limb system
so um i i guess
i don't want to get really into the
depths of
um what the regulatory requirements are
for everything because i'd be here all
day um
so i i just want to focus on
samples and um
i guess clinical samples fall between
that space
of gcp on one hand and glp in the other
um so that's as i'm sure you're all
aware
called gclp and i've put
some further reading at the bottom if
you do want to go and explore the depths
of it um got the whole guidelines and a
few other things
that you can content yourself with
um so for now i'm just going to
focus on the samples and i guess
with when you're talking about
guidelines and they're always open to
interpretation
so you'll ask one auditor um what they
expect and they'll give you one answer
and you'll get a completely different
an answer from an auditor the following
week
so what i want to do is concentrate on
the aspects that are not in my view
are not open to interpretation um
so that starts with chain of custody
probably the most
um important thing that i'll be talking
about today
that's locations of samples where you're
storing them
when and how you're shipping them sample
receipt
and sample receipt i cannot
express enough is probably the thing
that's recorded
um least well uh people seem to think
oh the shipments arrived we mark it as
received
that's good enough no it's not um
so that's something that uh we should be
focusing on
at the the sample level um
the second thing is consent and i guess
you might be thinking well
um the clinical team are responsible for
consent
and they absolutely are they're
responsible for making sure
um that what is in the protocol is
consented for
um so we could take the attitude well if
it's in the protocol
then we know it's consented so we're
good to go but actually
particularly with oncology studies um
you'll get quite a number of samples
that
require additional consent so the
non-mandatory samples
um they're optional and in that case
you want to make absolutely sure that
every sample
that you come across is consented and
that you're
fine to analyze and deal with it
the third thing here is a an audit trail
um that's really important it's no good
to say
it started at clinic 10 and ended up
in lab 2. um you want to know
all the stages in between hand as well
and lastly uh what we all love are uh
their csvs um and having
been um in in the the clinical space for
such a long time
um i was actually surprised when i went
to look at lem systems and started to
evaluate them
that they're not all 21 cfr part 11
compliant
and so it's just something to be aware
of i was quite shocked
um you just expect uh that they all will
be but not all limbs
are um made with uh clinical trials
in mind or even glp in mind so
something to remember i
do apologize uh um for the alerts there
um so it never fails to amaze me how
really quite senior um members of the
clinical team
think that sample operations are really
quite straightforward
and something that just seems to happen
um
so why
let's take this example of just a phase
two trials this is not even getting into
phase three
in the big studies um global data
has the number of sites the average
number of sites
um for phase two trial to be deployed
and if you say between 1 and 300
patients for a phase 2 study so let's go
for 200 here
and then with biomarker samples i've got
40 aliquots
per patient here really that's quite low
between 40 and 100 aliquots
per patient so we take 40 already we're
on to 8 000
um aliquots to look after and track
and if we take um
our 27s at the top here we have our 27
sites
and we have five laps and you might
think well
why on earth would we have five labs
well actually with biomarker trap
trials and much more complex trials
it's very unusual that you can send all
your samples to
a central laboratory and that there will
not be the need to
use reference labs niche labs
that are looking at specific markers so
we've got in our example
five labs that's not unheard of
and this is just one shipment if you
think a phase two trial will take
between two and three years
you're going to be looking of upwards
shipping
one month to three months every quarter
um
you're not gonna have 20 shipments per
site
that i i didn't try and plot that out
but it gives you an example if you're
looking for your one
half mil aliquot um of a particular
marker
um trying to track it you've got to have
a reliable system and you can see here
that with these sorts of numbers really
an excel spreadsheet
and they are still used is not really
appropriate
so here's my one negative slide and
we'll we'll try and pass over it quite
quickly
um i've put these pitfalls down
really because this is what i've
experienced i've come across
each and every one of these um so we
start with freezer management
uh i don't think anybody that's ever
been into
minus 80 freezer to try and find the
sample
um will dispute the fact that good
uh freezer management is absolutely
essential
um and if it's not if we get um
a site phoning us up as happens fairly
frequently um saying no we don't have
this sample we can't find this sample in
our freezer
do we deduce then that the sample's not
been taken
and not marked as not taken or do we do
just that we've shipped it
and it's not been marked as shipped or
is it still
in the freezer somewhere and that
usually ends up where it is
um then the other things that i've have
here uh duplication of sample id
you're going to have a lot of replicated
data
in your trial so you're going to have
the same visit number
um the same biomarker name the same time
point
so the only things that are distinct are
the
unique sample id and the patient number
um so if that patient number has not
been written down properly
you have no point of reference so
duplication of sample id is
nigh on impossible if you have a good
limb system to do
and i'll hold my hands up and say in the
early days of calibri
we did have some duplications and that
was due to the way we had set up the
limbs we've now protein measures
um that prevents that so all that's
possible with the limb system
very very easy to do duplicate a
sample id if you're just using an excel
spreadsheet
you've got the added complication of too
many systems and by that i mean
independent system so you have your
trial master file
and clinical records you'll have your
lab limb system
some form of sample tracking system to
name a few
what you need is an overarching system
um
and that's what we use our limbs for and
i've put down here
transportation tracking so you have your
sample that's coming from your site and
it's going to be
marked as ship and it's going to be
marked as received at the lab
what happens in that intermediate point
and that's particularly important when
you're shipping by air
it might take a few days
we had one example in the very early
days of covid where
getting samples on a plane was extremely
difficult and we had a sample that took
three weeks to get to south
africa so it's it's really important to
be able to track your samples even
during transportation
i've put down here incorrect manifest so
your manifest
if you think about glp being the
processes by which
um you plan perform monitor record and
report
um data then
your manifest is essentially your
planning
that's what you're going to ship um
it's your report that's what you have
shipped
and then um you're reporting your
final report is really your signature of
receipt that those
samples have been received and we try
and stress
parasites that are manifest is
it's not a requested document it's a
mandated document
um so um when
you find that uh the the site thinks oh
well we've got an extra couple of
samples we'll just slip those in
um or we can't find those two that are
on the manifest so
we'll ship those at another time those
sorts of things go on
time and again so an accurate manifest
is really really important for for good
tracking
and um lastly the bane of my life
are handwritten labels please please
please
type your labels as much as possible
print your
labels you're always going to have
a handwritten subject ids
because they're not normally known until
the the patient's actually being bled
but before that everything else please
print
um and all these um
pitfalls for one of a better word they
all stem
from human error we are human
we're going to make errors and in a busy
lab
the poor nurses are run ragged they're
not just managing your study they're
managing multiple studies
they've got multiple patients usually
quite complex sampling regimes
so things go wrong and by automating as
much as possible
of your um sample workflow then you can
help
reduce the errors across the
whole life cycle
so the rest of uh talk we'll look at how
we can avoid
these pitfalls and hopefully get to a
much
happier place so here i do apologize
if there are any um limbs vendors
um in the audience that i've not put up
here i have tried
to cover as many as possible um
[Music]
i'm not going to i'm not even going to
mention which ones i validate are
looked at evaluated um but i will say
because we're presenting um on how we
use
our limb system um i think it's fair to
to say that we use um the cloud glimpse
um
limb system uh not surprising
that's a cloud-based system um and
uh we've we find it great for us so
we'll go into
some of the the reasons for that in in a
bit
um what i would say here um
not all limbs are built for the same
purpose
so a limbs that's built um as a freezer
management um piece of software
within the same lab um
will not be the same as a limbs that's
required to
um track samples from a multi-centered
clinical trial so just bear that in mind
and i've now lost the next button here
we go so looking
um at the sample life cycle then you've
got the sample being collected
um hopefully that will be taken as per
the protocol
it will be recorded in the trial master
file that that's been collected
um the sample at that point is generally
stored in the clinic it may be shipped
out immediately if it's a whole blood
sample that needs analyzing
but generally stored in the clinic so it
goes into the clinic sample management
system
then your samples shipped somebody is
going to prepare a manifest
um however that system works
i'm going to be transported between air
or road and then it's going to be
received at the lab
again please remember record the receipt
of the samples and document those
inevitably there'll be a bit of
reconciliation because the labs got
enthusiastic
the clinic was enthusiastic and shipped
a few extra samples
um so you're on to the lab sample
management system then
probably a limb system and then it's
analyzed probably on the same system
data is transferred and reported and
finally
samples if it's a pk sample will
probably be destroyed after
a final report or it may be shipped back
to the the
originator to the site if it's a tumor
sample in particular
um the investigators they're clearly
very precious samples
investigators like them back um so
they'll be
returned to the investigator or if the
protocol
has given consent um it they could be
put into long-term storage for future
particularly by marker
examinations now i would say we have one
step
more to go on this um and that's at the
the kip stage so your kit
is where the sample ids your unique
sample ids
are present that are going to help that
whole
life cycle process and all of that
can be managed by your limbs so this
entire process
can be managed by your limbs if you have
the the correct limb size
i just have one more um thing to say
about labeling because
um it it's such a small thing but you
know it's absolutely
critical something goes wrong in your
label you have lost that sample
so a unique identifier is
um really important and that's often
linked to the barcode if you're using
barcodes
some clients don't particularly want to
use a barcode
excuse me um i think they're really
valuable things to have
even if your lab limbs is
a disconnected um system from your own
if you've got a bar code that can be
uploaded onto the lab limbs
um system no problem so it helps with
that
seamless transition and you can use one
or two d
bar chords and i i guess that's um
really up to personal preference calibri
we tend to use 2d because you can get
more
human readable um information on the
label
just from physically fitting and as
the bioanalyst in me that's really
useful to have
that's the last thing i'm going to
lecture on labeling
but those two items here these are
absolutely
um i would say crucial um to
maintain um your your sample tracking
so finally we get on to how
limbs are set up and i've
tried to separate it out into manual
processes
and what's managed either in a
completely automated way
or a semi-automated way um through the
limbs um so first thing we do when we
get a
um study in is create a sample upload
file
for a patient so each patient you know
exactly what samples
you're going to expect and that file is
created
no sample ids at all and that file is
uploaded
every time it's uploaded into the lim
system for a new patient
it will automatically create the sample
id
um automatically associate that with the
bar
code and that enables you to then select
the samples that you want to print and
print the labels
and make the kits um now some limbs
our olm system does allow um
the tracking of the kit inventory which
is really very useful
um but i won't go into that too much
because that's obviously not essential
for
um the regulatory aspects
so you ship your kits and the sample is
taken
and then i've got here location updated
and i'm going to come back to that in
the next slide
because that's a really key point of
when you see the visibility of that
sample
when is your limb system updated to say
hello this sample is no longer an empty
tube
it's got blood or plasma in it
and then from that you can prepare a
manifest and arrange
for the shipments they'll be the receipt
remember very important to receive your
samples um
and again up up
because it's now sitting at the lab it's
no longer sitting
at the clinic a little bit of
reconciliation here i've got that as a
manual process
i unfortunately haven't found a way to
automate that i would love to
and then analysis and reporting as well
can be done on the limbs so that is
pretty much
all of your process um by that initial
upload
and i've just put in here check consent
um
so this is where you can
customize your limbs so that for
particular samples if they're not
mandated samples
that you can have a checkbox um and and
just
make sure that that sample you've
received the patient has consented on it
and that will keep you straight with jcp
so going back to this locations and when
you actually see the visibility
of the sample um so there are two kind
of main
ways um that
the whole trial works one is to ship to
a central lab and this the samples are
then distributed from there
and the other is to ship directly from
um the the clinical site to the
laboratory um
so if we look at them then the the first
one you've got your limbs is
exactly i'm just going to come a little
bit closer to the screen because
my old eyes can't see what i'm doing
here that's better
so the lims is expecting a sample
the sample is collected then it's
shipped to the central facility
at that point that is when
you have visibility that the sample
exists
um and similarly if the samples are
shipped directly you've got your limbs
expecting the samples the samples
collected
and then you need a way of
copying that paperwork to the person
managing
the limbs um and that is
triggered that the the sample has now
been collected
now this time if that's done on the day
that's
fantastic unfortunately very busy
clinics um
it tends to be considerably more than a
day
um and then the limbs is updated
so you know here it's quite late in the
day or could be quite late in the day
before your limbs even knows that the
sample exists
and if you think back gcp or um
gclp um wants you to maintain chain of
custody
and part of that chain of custody starts
from the minute the sample is taken
so we're very lucky that we have a
really good relationship with cloud
limbs
and that's meant that we've been
involved in future developments and
we've been able to contribute
to how a future development could look
and work in the clinical space
and one such development is um
well it's they call it a client portable
portal we use it as a clinic
or lab interface so here and if we go to
stage one
we've got um the limbs expecting the
sample as before
this time the nurse taking the sample
can log in to our limbs from the portal
scan the sample that they're about to
take
and the system will prompt them for uh
two
pieces of information which they would
need to write down anyway
of the manual process and that's patient
id
and the date that it's taken done
that's all they need to do so where
our limbs is got notification from
um real time that that sample
now exists um so that that's
changed um our compliance
uh considerably and then lastly we have
an audit trail really important as i
said at the beginning
not just to understand that a sample was
expected
and then at some point in the line um
it's been taken and disposed of you've
got to know all the points
in between um so on the the top left
here
we have um a short from
a limb system the um each sample
will be an individual line and each one
has this log attached to it and you
simply
click on the log and if we look here
all these entries are for sample cl
one three um i have edited it slightly
we don't um like to put people's names
in presentations so
here we've got mickey mouse has created
uh
the sample that's got being expected on
the 22nd of january
uh this year um the
paperwork is required um but at that
time it hadn't been received the sample
didn't exist
and then we received it now we received
it on the 10th of
the sorry the 7th of april um but you
can see
here that the collection date um was
actually i can't see that the 9th of
march
um 21. so that's nearly a month that
it's taken
um to to get that uh
paperwork and the visibility of the
sample so that's where your
client portal is really very important
but at least we can document that we we
know that that's what's happened
at that time the sample has changed from
pending to
um that it's sitting at the clinical
site and then somewhere later we've got
donald duck has
um arranged for shipment uh on the 12th
of may
and the sample's been shipped from the
site
in this case uh to our own lamps
um and this is being held in this
freezer in this box and if you click on
that again
you'll find out exactly the position of
the box
so you have a full audit trace um trail
that's
very easy to bring back for any sample
so if we just recap then and go back to
what the regulatory expectations are
um so have we managed to address them
all
with their limbs um well
i would say pretty much um everything in
pink
we have managed by our limb system um
the only thing that i would say um a
little question mark on
is the shipping records and i don't mean
have
the um the actual samples been received
we do record that in the limbs
um but we don't currently
use it for courier paperwork so we're
not
would not recording that the box was
received containing samples
and we keep that manually so that's the
only aspect
of our whole sample workflow that isn't
on our lym
system so i hope
um that that's showing you that um it's
it's very easy to set up
manage the whole workflow um
reduce errors reduce that human
um possibility of making a human error
um by increasing the automation um
this is a rather odd situation where
we're recording
um up front um so i would normally say
please feel free to ask me any questions
i'll address there and i'll be more than
delighted
um if you want to uh reach out to me um
at any point in time and we can discuss
your situation so thank you very much